[Musique]
à la fois quoi de la comédie et génie du
drame molière à 400 ans cette année et
il est bien vivant et un fait peu un
effet passé 400 spots par un togo au
dessus jeunes impertinents forme de
taches et portion genre ada de moitié
jean baptiste poquelin dit molière est
né le 15 janvier 1622 à paris il est
l'auteur d'une trentaine de pièces de
théâtre des classiques comme l'école des
femmes le misanthrope la proches des
humains et le malade imaginaire
au québec il a été joué 49 fois au
théâtre du nouveau monde qui a ouvert
ses portes en 1951 justement avec la
pièce l'avare depuis ce temps de la voir
et est monté cinq fois et l'avoir dès
qu'on parle de ceux de ceux de cette
pièce ben c'est le tnm et jean gascon
roux jean louis roux olivier reichenbach
moi même on est tous restés fidèles à la
molière que pourrait vous dire vous si
je vous fait dire maintenant que les
galeries tariquet cette fidélité ici au
québec est dû au mordant jamais égalé de
molière normand chouinard a joué dans
cinq pièces de molière et le garde du
souvenir du tartuffe mais non ma dernier
pour être pour être des veaux je n'en
suis pas moins homme
1,12 à 12 pieds
malien venait de faire de tartuffe un
cruiser comme on dit aujourd'hui mais
pour être des vous je ne suis pas moins
homme c'est madame où
j'ai envie de vous se mettre une douceur
à nulle autre
ils se sont re pavillon condor molière
avait la plume bien affûté sévère et sa
prose ont perduré même si le défi à
l'occasion le roi de france louis xiv
lit ou 20 helvétique pourquoi veux tu
que j'y crois benoît brière a joué le
rôle du valet sganarelle don dont le
joie qui prononce lui tout derniers mots
de la pièce et là il tend la main aux
rois et demande
à star vous l'avez eue ce que vous
vouliez mes gages mais il ya un stop et
six mois censuré je n'avais plus
d'argent je t'ai écrit une pièce
d'affaires plaisait clergé a star paye
quand même pas purement culotté jeu pour
écrire des affaires de même en pleine
phase du roi
molière et est aussi comédien il est
d'ailleurs décédé quelques heures après
être monté sur scène pour jouer son
malade imaginaire il avait seulement 51
ans
qui s'est passé dans mon absence je
viens vous parler de quelques petites
choses
le 400e anniversaire du plus grand homme
de théâtre français a été assombri par
la pandémie et la fermeture des théâtre
molière aurait sans aucun doute trouver
une façon de s'en moquer ici bush les
primes et radio canada
[Musique]